black china has that pregnancy glow at
the Daily Mail com seriously popular
yacht party on Wednesday the expectant
mom who already has three year old son
King opened up to ET about her pregnancy
I'm not having any pregnancy cravings
right now everything is norm one just
pregnant and I'm happy though literally
I'm just like all belly so yeah I'm
Polly looking jairo you think I'd be
having a brother I'm not gonna reveal
the gender yet but he told me that he
was a brother sister while China was
tight-lipped about the gender of her
first child with Rob Kardashian the
model revealed what kind of father she
thinks the reality star will be
overprotective the Fisher's loving
caring rob is just like a release a big
bundle of joy and we might get a
behind-the-scenes look of the couple
exchanging nuptials on their upcoming
reality series we are thinking about
having a wedding special
where are you out with your wedding for
breaking haven't started playing again
we go one thing at a time